SCOTT: Hi, everyone.
I'm Chef Scott.
I'm introducing Chef Georg from
the Ojai Valley Inn and Spa.
He's going to do some
cool stuff for you guys.
I hope you enjoy.
And have a good day after that.
GEORG PAULUSSEN:
The first one, we're
going to make an appetizer.
First one, we have a
heirloom tomato salad.
These ones are
heirloom tomatoes.
And we have them growing
at the Ojai Valley Inn
and Spa in our own herb garden.
And these are tomatoes with
a 5,000 year seed history.
So they're really, really
cool and very flavorful.
Many times when you go in
a supermarket-- and people
who maybe don't know, they
see tomatoes like that
and it's like, I
don't want to buy it.
They don't look very
pretty, And all that stuff.
But these are actually
really good, flavorful, tasty
tomatoes.
Then we got some
small ones here.
These are also grape tomatoes.
And they're also heirloom.
Then we got some other
herbs and spices,
which I'm going to
show you in a second.
So what we would like
to start-- and we
don't do this just
for television,
we're going to put
on some gloves.
And I believe that even
though-- if you maybe
cook at home and all that
stuff, it's always good
if you put your gloves on.
And then you don't have
no cross contamination.
All that stuff is good.
So I've got a couple
of tomatoes here,
which we're going to slice
in relatively big chunks.
So if you have six pieces
of a tomato like that.
And then we want to do a
couple of different colors.
Now, the flavor
profile is the same.
What is different is the look.
And I'll show you how
very different they look.
See?
And they're all ripe,
even though maybe they
have different colors.
But they all still
have the same texture.
And they kind of taste
the same, except that they
look different.
Some small differences is
maybe the flavor profile.
Then over here we have
some Meyer lemons.
Meyer lemons.
As you can see, these
ones are pixie oranges.
Meyer lemons are almost
like an orange from the look
and from the texture of
the skin and the inside,
except they're a lot sweeter.
So they're a little
bit a mixture
between a lemon, a
lime, and an orange.
Gives a very different
and unique flavor.
I'm going to squeeze
a little bit in there.
Unfortunately, they
have about 6,000 seeds,
so you want to make sure that
you don't get all of them
in there.
Just take a little
bit of lemon juice.
Then we have cold pressed
extra virgin olive
oil, cracked black pepper.
Very simple.
And a little bit of salt.
And then comes the fun part.
I have a little bit of honey.
About a tablespoon.
And what's really nice with the
lemon and the pixie flavor--
and a little bit of mustard.
We're going to make a dressing.
And this dressing
we'll be making here
is actually part of the
salmon dressing as well.
So you see?
Very simple.
And it emulsifies.
You want to make sure is that
the olive oil, the honey,
and all the juices
really going to mix well.
You take your tomatoes.
And then you just marinate
them in the dressing
for a little bit.
OK.
There you go.
Here's one of the short cuts
I was talking about earlier.
This one is a gravlax.
And what it is it's basically
a line caught Pacific salmon.
So it's the one which runs right
outside your waters out here.
Originally gravlax
means like a grave.
And it comes from Scandinavia.
And why is it a grave?
Yesterday, exactly
24 hours ago, I
made a mix out of
salt and sugar.
Equal parts.
I put juniper berries in
there, dill, black pepper,
a little bit of lemon juice,
and Worcestershire sauce.
I made that mix and put
the salmon in there.
And, as you can
see, overnight it
has basically taken out all the
natural juices of the salmon.
And as you all know,
there's ceviche.
It's all this kind
of stuff out the way,
you actually marinate them
with lemon and/or with spices.
This one is a different
kind from Scandinavia.
And the flavor profile comes
from the dill and the salt.
And it does the same
thing like a ceviche.
Just from a different
part of the world where
they have used them in a
different pickling way.
So this salmon, even
though it's not cooked--
and you get to taste
it in a second--
feels and looks cooked.
It's very, very delicious.
And it has changed the color
because it has taken out
all the natural juices.
And even just to show
you the back-- see that?
It's completely cooked.
Now the disadvantage
you have with something
like that-- if you leave it
in for longer than 24 hours
it becomes really salty.
Very, very strong.
And the saltier it
becomes, it's better
if you have the
juice of the lemon,
or the orange or a little bit
of lime and a little bit honey
because it counterfeits the
salty taste of the salmon.
So you'll see that in a second.
We have more.
Just wash this off please.
So we have the
tomatoes marinated.
You can do that
obviously a la minute,
which it means we'll do it right
now, right here for your guests
at home or for yourself.
You marinate a little
bit of salmon--
a little bit of
tomatoes, pardon me.
And then over here I have
some pre-washed gem lettuce.
Gem lettuce is a different
kind of romaine bibb lettuce.
It's very small, very unique.
And it has a very
small, delicate flavor.
And we'll just use
the heart of it.
And we'll use that as a garnish.
Every time you use a
lettuce, or every time you
use a tomato,
cucumber, whatever it
is, you want to give it
a little bit of dressing.
It's not too much.
And mix it all up.
If you have
questions, just shoot.
We don't need to
wait until the end.
If you want to know something.
So please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GEORG PAULUSSEN: Yes.
GEORG PAULUSSEN: You can.
You can.
You don't necessarily
need to do that.
The challenge is when you
do do that, you squeeze out
the juices much faster.
And it doesn't take the flavor
of the actual salt and sugar
mixture.
If you let it do it gradually
and slowly its own marinade,
then you get the flavor
all the way through.
Because if you imagine the
salmon is being squished
together, you have
no room to breathe,
even though you're dead.
But it doesn't go
through it all the way.
So we got the dead
salmon right here.
He's still all very happy.
And he's all
delicious right now.
And I'm going to cut
straight through the center.
You have seen from the
top, from the back.
And look how
beautiful that looks.
And it's very easy.
It's very delicate.
And it's very, should I
say, very easy to slice.
Let me make a
little bit of space.
I want to make sure
you can see this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GEORG PAULUSSEN: Yes.
Yes, you would refrigerate it.
So there's different
ways of slicing it.
You can slice it
straight through.
For our purpose, for
our presentation,
I like to do it like this.
Or you slice it-- if you want
to make a nice gravlax bagel
sandwich in the
morning or something,
then you slice it like this.
What is important as you slice
not just this, as you slice
anything at home, let
the knife do the work.
Don't let your elbows-- don't
let your arm do the work.
Let the knife flow
through your product.
And as you can see, if you can
read a newspaper through it,
you did a good job.
That's how thin
it's supposed to be.
If it's thicker, it's
not going to taste good.
So the more newspaper you can
read, the happier you will be.
All right.
So we take a little
bit of salmon.
Make sure there
are no bones in it.
And, again, if you
don't like salmon,
or if you like a different kind
of fish-- you like halibut,
you like tuna-- you can do it
with all these kinds of fish.
You can do it the same way.
A different marinade from Asia.
I used to work in
Japan for many years.
In Asia and Japan they do
the same style with a salmon
or with a tuna, but you would
use soya sauce and ginger
and garlic and chili peppers.
So wherever you go
around the world,
the principal of a
marinated fish is the same,
but the flavor profile
is completely different.
So now we have these
marinated tomatoes.
As you can see,
what's really nice is
the contrast of the
different colors.
We have a couple of pieces
of a little gem lettuce.
And then we take a couple of--
make sure all of this stuff
is washed.
We got enough
protein on the plate.
We don't want more
protein on it.
OK.
And then you see the
dressing is still emulsified.
Take a little bit of that.
Put it on the salmon.
And how fast was that?
Now if we forget about
that little sucker which
is 24 hours old, this
was relatively fast.
That was five
minutes, 10 minutes.
And you have a really cool,
great looking appetizer.
It's always coming
down in a kitchen.
We talk about mise en place.
Mise en place is the production,
which is in its place
before we start.
Once you have all
this stuff lined up,
it's going to go really fast.
So what I'll do, I'll
slice a few more pieces
and then Moe is going to
give you some sample plates.
And you guys can take
five minutes or something
to taste it.
And then I'm going to go
and start the next course.
Sounds good?
All right.
So now is the music.
Where's the music?
Make me work for a living here.
OK.
More.
You ready?
Any other questions?
I only look like a chef,
but I'm not that mean.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GEORG PAULUSSEN: I see.
Now you had to do that.
Who said that?
I wasn't looking up.
Just kidding.
I'm from Germany.
I was born and
raised in Germany.
And I left the
country when I was
22-years-old to work
on a cruise ship.
And some of you younger
folks maybe don't know,
but you used to have a
television show in the US.
It was called "The Love Boat."
And we had the same
thing in Germany.
The German "Love Boat."
And I joined that one.
It was the first time
when I actually left
my village where I came from.
And I liked it so much.
And I said, wow, I get to be
able to see the whole world.
And I get paid for it.
So I left and I never
went back-- only to visit.
OK.
Here we go.
I started in Germany.
And then from Germany, my
first outside the country job
was New York.
And I've said that
story before when--
let me start it a different way.
I started in Germany.
I did my apprenticeship.
I did my whole stuff
with "The Love Boat."
And then I came to US.
And we had 1,500 people
living in my village.
So that's how small it was.
And I went to a city in New
York with 15 million people.
I didn't speak a
word of English.
Hi, hello, that was it.
That's all I could say
for the first six months.
And I started learning English
on watching "Wheel of Fortune."
I couldn't answer a single thing
about what they were saying,
but I was listening to the
letters, the pronunciation,
the ABC, and all that stuff.
And eventually it
started making sense.
And then like you do
in every language,
the first thing I
knew was how to cuss
in New York, and all that stuff.
How to talk bad
language, especially
in the kitchen, as you know--
well, maybe as you have heard.
So I did this.
And then from New
York I went to London,
worked in London for
one and a half years.
Came back to New York, and I
worked in New York and Boston,
and then left the
US for four years
to go to work in Tokyo, Japan.
Worked also with a couple of
stints in New Delhi, India
and in Hong Kong, Singapore.
Then I was tired of Asia.
Came back to the US and worked
in '97 with Caesar's Palace
in Las Vegas, was then
the Executive Chef
at the Venetian in Las Vegas,
worked there for two years
and left the US again and went
to the Atlantis in the Bahamas.
And I worked there
for three years.
And then from Bahamas, I
went back to Las Vegas,
worked there for
seven years, had
my own restaurant
and catering company.
And then as the whole economy
went down, I went down.
I mean, business is still alive.
So that's all good.
But I sold the business.
And then after
that, I went to work
for Trump International
in Las Vegas.
And then I went one year
to the cold in Kansas City.
And I didn't like that.
And now I'm finally
in California,
where I believe I belong,
where I'm the happiest.
It's kind of like home where
I come from in Germany.
I mean, obviously, we
don't have an ocean
like you have over here.
We got the cold North Sea.
And it's really gray,
and that's pretty.
But we got the mountains
and everything else.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GEORG PAULUSSEN: Sure.
GEORG PAULUSSEN: It's great.
You have a really
great eye for detail.
And the reason why I said
it's a Japanese knife,
and it's a Japanese
multi-utility knife.
You can use it for seafood,
for vegetables, for anything.
What is different on this
knife, as you can see,
it has four different
reflections almost.
Each different reflection is
a different kind of steel.
So this knife has
four different steels,
and they are being
pressed together.
By being pressed together,
they're much stronger,
and they're not getting as dull
as quickly as regular knives.
And on the top here,
you'll see them-- there's
very, very small.
You can't really see it.
There's a shiny, but there's
a little bit more shiny
in the middle.
The one in the middle,
all the way in the center,
is the sharpest, hardest
steel of all four of them.
But by having it like this,
you have a really great balance
when you cut with the knife.
And it stays sharper much
longer than a traditional knife.
And if you do want
to sharpen it,
you get it sharp
much, much faster.
You pull it over
a steel like this.
And if you know what you're
doing, you do it this way.
And if you don't,
you do it this way.
And there are many different
ways and all that stuff.
But with a regular,
cheaper knife
you can get in the supermarket,
you do this two or three times
and you have small little
ridges in the knife.
And, all of a sudden,
when you cut something
it rips the meat
or the vegetables
or something like that.
And when you have a really
good, expensive knife,
you can-- and I'm not doing
this just to prove the point.
But you can hit
really hard like that,
and nothing's going
to happen to it.
It stays.
OK.
And I guess the
appetizers are ready.
Whoever's first
please help yourself.
Take a picture of the appetizer.
What it looks like.
And then we're ready to go.
We got a little
bit more dressing.
Please help yourselves.
We got forks.
We got napkins.
And then right after that
we'll start the main course.
So you're hungry for more?
Me too.
Full mouth is a
happy mouth, right?
Or something like that.
OK.
Next one.
Next one on our menu,
we have a halibut.
And, again, I really believe
in marinating our seafood.
We got a nice, fresh
piece of halibut.
And we are going to
use a pixie orange.
They only grow in Ojai.
I don't know if you know that.
And they only grow within
the first part of spring.
And they have a slight
sour, orangey flavor.
So we got some more lemon juice.
We got this beautiful
pixie flavor.
And we have some cracked black
pepper and, of course, salt.
And what I like to
use for this one
is about a tablespoon
of Worcestershire sauce.
Just marinate it a little bit.
And if you do this
at home you can
put this in the refrigerator
for about an hour or two.
And just let it rest.
The best thing is like
seafood, or meat, or something,
if you let it slightly come
up to room temperature.
When it's too cold,
it takes too long
for the outside temperature
to get to the center.
And by the time it
gets to the center,
the outside is overcooked.
So if you have it
at room temperature
it's very easy for the
steak, for the meat,
or whatever you want to use,
for evenly the temperature
to develop.
We have just a regular pan here
with some extra virgin olive
oil.
And under normal circumstances,
meaning normal circumstances
at home or in a
professional kitchen,
I would have a big
baking oven behind me.
I would take the halibut
now, and I would sear it off.
It's not hot yet.
Would sear it off
from all four sides
because it's kind of
like a square log.
If it's only two sides,
you take from two sides.
And I would finish it in the
oven on the high temperature.
And the best is in
a convection oven
because the temperature
flows around it.
Keeps the outside
nice, closed up.
The pores can't run out.
And it stays juicy.
All right.
So with this one we're going
to sear off the halibut.
And then in the meantime,
we're going to start something
where it's called a Hollandaise.
A Hollandaise is a
traditional butter sauce.
And for this particular one,
I am going to use egg yolk.
I use white wine.
Maybe some hot water.
Then we are going to use
a little bit of Tabasco.
Again a tick of
Worcestershire sauce.
A lemon.
And you will see that once I
have seared off the halibut,
I'm going to put in
some fresh butter.
The fresh butter, even
though it makes it crispy,
it keeps it nice and moist.
And we're also going to
put in some fresh thyme
and a little bit
of fresh oregano.
Why fresh thyme and oregano?
Because we're having
some potatoes.
These potatoes are
being right now--
because of time
constraints they're
being roasted in
the oven right now.
And we're going to season
all of this together.
So we have here the egg yolk,
white wine, lemon juice mixed.
And the traditional way
of making a Hollandaise,
you make it with tarragon.
But today we don't
want to do traditional.
We want to use some dill.
And because of the application
we use-- bless you--
we're going to use a
little bit of mustard.
So it has a nice color.
And now what I'll do,
I'll put a piece of butter
in there to let it melt.
Why I don't put the
butter in right away?
It's going to burn before.
So that's why I'm going
to sear off the seafood,
or steak, or poultry,
whatever you like at home,
with some oil.
And then you put
the butter in there,
and it makes it nice and foamy.
And then you want to take a
little bit of fresh thyme.
You don't need to
chop the thyme.
And you can hear that
really nice crushing sound.
See?
And put it a little
bit on this side.
And you are ready to
flip the fish over.
And, again, as I
was saying before,
now would be the time
you put it in the oven.
And let the temperature
slowly seep through.
Cover it up.
And now work with me.
Zzz.
Here's the oven.
And put it in.
And done.
OK.
Good.
All right.
So clean up the oven.
In the meantime, I'm going
to put this on the side.
We're going to start
our sauce Hollandaise.
Can you give me a
little hot water?
Hot water.
You got some?
No, not in there.
Just in a--
What's important is
with the Hollandaise,
that you don't take the
egg and the egg white
and put it straight
on a hot stove.
What's going to happen, it's
going to make scrambled eggs.
So we want to put a little
bit of water in there
and make it kind of
like a steam bath.
Then we start whipping
the egg white like this.
That's the job for apprentices
in the kitchen when they just
start.
When you give them to make
a Hollandaise with 400 eggs,
it's going to take a few hours.
Well, at that time they
look like your old Governor
Schwarzenegger, or
somebody like that.
So it goes relatively fast.
As soon as the water
is hot it starts--
and I'll show you
the different stages.
You see, it starts foaming.
And you want to whip the base
of your Hollandaise up to a rose
And what I mean by a rose--
and I'll show in a second.
You take a wooden spoon or
you take a regular spoon,
and you take the back of the
spoon and you blow on it.
Once you blow on it and it
starts to look like a rose,
that means it has enough cooked
the egg yolk and the egg white.
And all the flavors emulsified
enough to receive the butter.
And we use clarified butter.
If you would use regular
butter, straight melted,
it has too much
water content in it.
And it would break
your Hollandaise.
So what we do, we bring
the butter to a boil
and let the water, so
to speak, and the milk
processes sink to the
bottom of the butter.
You see this?
How thick this got?
How fast?
All right.
Now what you want to do is,
you want to take it down.
You don't want to
keep on whipping it
under too much temperature
because then we
can still going to end
up with scrambled eggs.
So that's good.
OK.
Now I'll show you what it
means blowing into a rose.
And I'm going to
put that spoon back.
I don't want you guys to say,
oh, he's blowing in my food.
I don't know if
you can see this.
But when you blow it,
it gets these ridges.
And it looks like a rose.
And you see it's
sticking to the spoon.
Now if you use too
much clarified butter,
it will break.
So what you want
to do is you want
to either do it by the spoon.
If you're by yourself, you
can do a spoon at a time.
And if you know what you're
doing, you can pour it in.
And your bowl comes to life.
Thank you.
Very, very slow.
If you do it too fast your
Hollandaise will break.
And when I say break, it means
the egg yolk and the butter
won't emulsify.
And it's going to look bad and
taste even worse because you're
going to have the
grizzle kind of flavor.
OK.
Now look how cool and
how fast it looks.
It's like the same principle
as you make a mayonnaise.
Except with the
mayonnaise you would
have cold egg yolks
the traditional way,
and you use with olive
oil, a little bit of salt,
pepper, lemon juice,
and all that stuff.
But this one is a
hot sauce, which
we're using for our halibut.
Is the fish ready?
And can you give me
the potatoes, please?
So as I was saying
before, our magic oven
just created some
beautiful roasted potatoes.
And these are just regular
fingerling potatoes
you can purchase
in any supermarket.
I just cooked them.
Cut them in half.
And then we have a herb
mix, which is just, again,
a little bit of
thyme and oregano
as I started with
in the beginning.
And once they're sliced in
half, after you cook them,
you can keep them over
night for multiple days.
Or you do like we do.
You just heat it up in
the oven as you need it.
And then put that in the
center of your plate,
or however you want
to make it look.
Very simple.
I want to show this.
So our Hollandaise is ready.
It has now nicely settled.
And because of the
temperature difference,
it got a little bit thicker.
That's our halibut.
And then we have a few
regular heirloom beets.
Now what's special
about these beets?
Nothing.
These are just regular beets
you can buy in the supermarket.
And all I did with these beets,
I put them in aluminium foil,
a little bit of salt,
pepper, and maple syrup.
So very simple.
You take them.
You put them in the foil.
Make a little pouch.
And bake them in the
oven until they're done.
When they're done,
you want to peel them
because when they're hot the
skin comes off really easy.
Again, I've done
that the day before.
Or you can do it also the
same time as you cook.
You take them out.
And then just in
the last moment you
want to put in little
bit of fresh salt,
a little bit of cracked pepper.
And just give them a
small little saute.
And then just place them around.
So you can see the food
we're cooking today
is not very difficult to do.
But it's very fresh, very
healthy, and very colorful.
Something easy you can do.
If you want to
live super healthy,
you put another beet there.
There you go.
And that's it.
That's very simple.
Very quickly done.
And, again, most of this work
you can do the day before,
except your Hollandaise.
You'll do that
fresh a la minute.
Now I'm going to do the
same thing as we did before.
We'll make you a
few sample plates.
The advantage from
fish to seafood
is you have these
different layers-- flakes.
And if you're not 100%
when a fish is done,
you can touch it from the side.
You don't necessarily want
to touch it from the top.
In the meat, you
do it from the top.
And I'll tell you in a second.
When you touch the seafood
from the side like this
and the flakes slowly
start to separate--
you don't want them to
completely fall apart--
that means your
fish is overcooked.
Then it's really dead this time.
But you want to have a
little bit of life in it.
So you just touch it.
And as you see, these small
little fish membranes,
so to speak, are falling apart.
That's the right temperature.
Now with a piece of meat,
with a steak or something,
you touch it from the
top because obviously it
doesn't have these
flakes to break apart.
Very simple.
I'll show you.
When you hold your hand
like that-- and you
can all do it with me.
If you hold your
hand totally relaxed,
and you press this
part below your thumb,
that means the cow
is still alive.
Now basically it's rare.
That's how the steak is rare.
So all you need to do now
is no pressure, no nothing.
Just open your hand.
Just open.
No pressure.
Touch that same area again.
And you feel a bit of
a difference already.
Now it's when the
steak is medium rare.
Now open your hand
as hard as you can.
Really stretch it.
And touch it again.
Now it's medium.
Now you close your
hand like this
and put a certain
amount of pressure on it
so that your
fingernails slightly
dig into the center
of your hand.
And press it again.
You feel the difference now?
Now it's medium well.
And now you really make a fist
like you want to hit something.
Now it's well done.
Really easy, right?
So you can do it right here.
And some other people
they do it here.
You can do it also.
But this is the easiest
way for me to do.
Start from rare all
the way to well done.
Very easy.
So this was rare.
This is well done.
So you just open your hand.
You're medium.
So you're already half there.
Make sense?
Kind of.
OK.
I'm in the Ojai.
And I'm still
counting the month.
I'm at 11 months.
And, like I said before,
I really like it here.
I really hope this
is going to work out.
And my job is
very, very exciting
because we are--
our food at the Ojai
is very much driven by
the heart of California.
So as you can see,
all these fresh fruits
and all these fresh
vegetables and all this stuff
is relatively easy to cook with.
Many times I've worked
around the world and chefs,
they have food
and they create it
into something
else what it's not.
Why make a salmon taste like
a steak if it's a salmon?
Or whatever.
Many times you go into a
fancy restaurant and people
want to be so creative.
And it's like, let me make a sea
bass with a strawberry sauce.
Why?
Just because you
want to be creative?
want to be different?
No.
So that's why I love being
in the property I'm in now.
Many of these vegetables,
many of these fruits,
are being cooked on property.
They grow in this
particular area here.
And we're just heating
them up and just give it
a little bit of
additional flavor.
Just make it a
little bit different.
A little bit to maple syrup.
A little bit of honey.
Or a little bit of tangerines.
A little bit of jalapeno.
Which is all in this area.
And it makes it very
different and very unique.
It gives a very fresh flavor.
If they're good chefs,
they don't really
do nothing different.
Well, it's true.
And the reason why
I say that, it's
all again in the
so-called mise en place.
The mise en place,
I'll do this now
if I wanted two proportions.
But if you do it in big cruise
ships or big operations,
like when I worked at the
Atlantis or at the Venetian,
we would still do the
same kind of food.
You just multiply it.
And everything is larger.
So we don't have one pan.
We have a pot where
you can climb into
and you can do 600 pieces
of fish at the same time.
Or we have these ovens in
these big operations where
I can cook 600 chicken
breasts in about 15 minutes.
And that's just one oven.
And you have 10 all lined
up next to each other.
So it's a very different thing.
But it's still the same potato.
It's still the same beet.
It's still the same fish.
It doesn't matter.
It's all coming down to
the preparation time.
How you do it and
when you do it.
Please don't be shy.
Help yourself.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GEORG PAULUSSEN: I have
some wild strawberries here.
And I'm not going to put the
strawberries in the sauce.
I'd like you to just
taste the strawberries.
And so I'm going to put
them on the garnish.
They taste very different.
Very unique.
They have a little wild flavor,
but they're extremely sweet.
And they taste like
strawberries the way
they used to taste
40, 50 years ago
when it wasn't so
commercialized.
And when you would
go in a field and you
would pick your
own strawberries.
And all that stuff.
This is really the old style.
100% organic.
Really a delicious flavor.
So I'd like you to taste these.
These ones here are
not bad strawberries,
but these are the
strawberries you
buy in a regular supermarket.
And what we're
doing today, we're
going to make
spaghetti ice cream.
Now is when you're
supposed to say, ooh.
All right.
OK.
We're there now.
Hello.
All right.
So I got some honey.
Honey for the honey.
OK.
A little bit of honey.
And maple syrup.
Let's put some more in there.
And put some powdered
sugar in there.
Powdered sugar's good.
Sugar's good for the nerves.
Especially chefs, they
need a lot of sugar.
They have a lot of nerves.
All right.
Good.
Honey.
Honey is good.
And some booze.
Yeah, of course.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GEORG PAULUSSEN: So this
one is a magic wand.
Maybe some of you
have it at home.
But if you don't
have it at home,
you just put it in
a regular blender,
or you chop it up by
hand or something.
And you're just making a
fresh strawberry sauce.
Now as I was saying before,
it's all about fresh food.
Fresh and simple and fast.
There's no cooking involved.
All natural ingredients.
That's it.
Very easy.
Fresh strawberry sauce.
So now you want to know how
we make spaghetti ice cream.
Spaghetti ice cream.
What do we need for spaghetti?
We need a good tomato sauce.
Here's our tomato sauce.
We need a good Parmesan cheese.
Parmesan cheese are grated
hazelnuts and walnuts.
That's our Parmesan cheese.
Then we need, of
course, ice cream.
And we need whipped cream.
The world I come
from a good ice cream
doesn't exist without
some whipped cream.
What's cool with
the whipped cream,
it has cinnamon and a little
bit of vanilla sugar in there.
And then, you can buy these
in any house ware store.
These are potato ricers.
They don't cost much.
They maybe cost, I don't
know, $15 or something.
Say, ooh.
Ice cream spaghetti.
So you squeezed that out.
And what's really cool making
spaghetti ice cream like this,
is that even though it's
still just vanilla ice cream--
there's nothing
special about it.
That because you put in
there, it's very fluffy.
It tastes different
because of that alone.
You have air in it.
And it's going to
melt relatively fast.
And now we're going to put
our beautiful delicious tomato
sauce on there.
Mm.
Put a couple of chopped nuts,
which is Parmesan cheese.
And then take a few of these
strawberries around there.
Very simple food for home.
If you want to make it
special, cut the green off.
I leave the green on.
I need rough edge.
I'm a chef.
I need some good stuff.
And that's it.
Basically very easy to do.
Very quickly to do.
And I'm going to do the same
thing for you now over there.
I'm going to make some
spaghetti ice cream.
And you can do it any other way.
If?
You don't like strawberries,
either raspberry,
or if you do it at a children's
party, you use blackberries.
You can do all different
kinds of flavors
and have the creativity
of your guests
or of your kids come
up what is the sauce.
If it's a blackberry, you
make a black ink fish sauce,
spaghetti, and stuff like that.
It's really cool.
It's a great interaction
with your kids.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GEORG PAULUSSEN: Strawberries,
maple syrup, honey,
and powdered sugar.
And a little bit of that.
So if the party's
only for you guys
and you like to spruce it up,
you put a little bit of rum
in there, or something
else, what makes you smile.
And everything's good.
OK.
Let me make some ice cream
and you guys come forward.
And we'll be done.
OK, folks.
That's it.
I hope you had fun.
And I'll see you
again up the road.
6,000 miles or
something like that.